the trends that I'm seeing today well
first of all I think it's absolutely
fascinating how the word
environmentalist and the the
environmental movement let's say has
gone from something really ghetto wised
even 10 years ago I think it was easily
demonized and you could say
environmentalist and you could really
dismiss someone pretty easily to today
where I mean every multinational
corporation is figuring out how to to
market themselves as green or
sustainable or environmental and you
know you could argue that it's being
co-opted and commercialized in such a
way that doesn't even have meaning
anymore and the effect of it is of these
kind of green or sustainable like acts
are really meaningless because they have
so little effect or they're so minimal
in comparison to the crisis that we're
facing but I think it's a positive thing
that that people are taking it seriously
and but it if you if you just just
looked at that cultural shift I think
it's pretty phenomenal how quickly
people's mindsets can change given the
circumstances that we live in so I think
that's one thing for sure in terms of
architecture and an art I'm I'm I'm
amazed at how far we've come from 20
years ago when i was in architecture
school to this time of kind of these
superstar architects and this I think
these a lot of empty formalism which
maybe I referred to previously about
just beauty and aesthetics to I think I
think we're living in a moving towards a
very sophisticated time in architecture
and design specifically where I am
amazed to see even how how architecture
and design are talked about in the press
where we think we expect a lot more from
architecture and design than we did in
the 70s and 80s and I think people are
more savvy about it and and they're more
critical and
people feel more comfortable talking
about it and demanding more from the
world that we live in in terms of the
architecture and design we're creating
the world of art I think it's it's a
very different world it's a it's a very
different discourse that's happening
there and I think I I I guess my biggest
disappointment in in the art world
today's is the commercial system that
props it up and I think I think we're
we're all suffering from from it in some
ways I think I think a more critical
thoughtful and powerful art would would
emerge if if the is the contemporary
commercial system that it's a part of
opened up or if the artist started to
question it more or find other ways to
practice I think I think today more than
ever we need artists and we need
architects who are really powerful
agents in society stepping outside of
the little boxes that are made for them
or given to them when they go into
school or indoctrinated into and take
charge of their practices and take
charge of the way there they're
operating in the world and I think I
think today in in the art world I was
starting to see that open up and I do
think actually with with this whitney
biennial we're starting to see it open
up we're starting to see you know a
large percentage of the artists in the
show aren't roads that represented
commercially and don't show at galleries
but have really complicated practices
that take them out into the real world
in ways that we haven't seen as much
before which i think is very exciting